good morning everyone if you all could
go ahead and take your seats I'd
appreciate it we're gonna get started on
day three of energy week it's been a
remarkable couple of days we're very
glad that you're here today and we're
very excited about the speakers that we
have so a couple of housekeeping items
for this morning as we start the day the
first is just a reminder to please
silence your cell phones tablets
anything that beeps we want to make sure
that we do that first
for questions we are using an app called
slide oh so you don't I'm sorry I keep
saying it's an app you just download you
just put it in to your browser slider
comm and then you're able to put in a
code and that code is that on each of
the slides that have the presenter and
you can insert the questions that you
have for that particular for that
particular speaker we will be sending
out a survey at the end of our event and
we're very interested in your feedback
so please do answer that survey if you
have specific comments or questions you
can also email us directly it turns out
that my email is on it in a number of
different places so you can certainly
find a way to reach me in terms of
thanks it's always good to start the day
with thank you a special thank you today
to Amanda King who has been running
around behind the scenes and making a
lot of the magic happen
so I wanted to make sure that we think
in terms of sessions today we are
starting with Andrew place and I'm gonna
hold on talking about Andrew for a
minute because we have a special
introduction for Andrew at 10:30 our
English department is giving a
presentation or having a panel
discussion about the humanities and
energy for those of you who are here
yesterday you saw a dramatic monologue
competition we are very
cross-disciplinary here at Carnegie
Mellon and so this is a very good way
for us to sort of showcase that by
having some areas outside of the typical
ones that you would think about for
energy we will have lunch between 11:15
11:45 and then Chris white who is the
newly named CEO of philips Lighting will
be presenting at 11:45 so on the agenda
it has lunch and Chris together because
it is a lunchtime session Chris will
start promptly at 11:45 and I'll remind
you of that when we get closer at 12:30
we will have the the official kickoff
for the allegheny clean tech university
prize collegiate competition and at
during that point we'll have one minute
pitches from each of the teams so it's
an exciting time to see those teams and
they have worked very hard to prepare
for this we have tours scheduled between
1:30 and 3:30 we have a tour to
Hazelwood green which is the 178 acre
Brown field that's being redeveloped in
the city of Pittsburgh we have a walking
hardhat tour of Tepper quad we still
have a few spaces available in some of
these so make sure that if you're
interested you show up at the
registration desk we have another that's
going to the hilltop urban farm again a
couple of spaces still available we want
to make sure that that bus is full and
there's a walking tour of Scott Hall
including the nanotechnology laboratory
we'll be talking about that specifically
the pitches and part of the competition
today are all being moderated by
Jeanette Armstrong who is the director
of the office of Technology transitions
for the US Department of Energy so she
will be with us throughout the course of
the day as we have the competition the
different segments of that competition
between 3:30 and 5:00 o'clock there's a
student poster competition and during
breaks and lunch you will actually see
that many of the posters are already set
up there are 38 posters that are
competing and so many of you are
actually serving as judges for that so
very excited about all of that student
work 38 posters is a lot of posters for
us to judge today at 5 o'clock we'll
have our three finalists from the day
from the clean tech competition on stage
to do 10 minute pitches and then we'll
make those announced
at 6 o'clock this evening we actually
are partnering with sustainability
weekend and we will have a lecture from
Balaji Ganapathy who is with Tata
Consultancy Services he's the global HR
and head of workforce and then our final
evening reception this evening will be
also in partnership with sustainability
weekend so this morning I'm very glad to
present our our speaker as well as one
of our best business partners from the
city of Pittsburgh Alex pazzo Kennex
alex is a CMU alum he's also the
assistant director of mobility and
infrastructure for the city of
Pittsburgh
he studied in the Heinz College in
information systems and public policy
and he currently serves as the assistant
director of mobility and infrastructure
for the mayor for mayor William Peduto
in the city of Pittsburgh he's also a
board member of the Carnegie Lyme
library of Homestead so Alex
thank you Anna
as Anna mentioned I am the assistant
director of the city of Pittsburgh's new
department of mobility and
infrastructure we have two charges in
our name brand new department as of a
year ago mobility and infrastructure how
we move about our city and how we
preserve those existing assets that we
already have and there's no five people
in Pennsylvania who have more of an
impact on the way that we do that in the
innovation that comes along with that
than the Pennsylvania Public Utilities
Commission there's a reason that the
Commissioner place and and the other
members of the Commission were the cover
models for the February issue of public
utilities fortnightly which I swear to
God is a real publication I guess in
this crowd you probably are all
subscribers to it the Pennsylvania
Utilities Commission both in terms of
helping to see the transformation around
traditional utilities like electric and
natural gas but also in the regulation
and the balance between consumer and
public interests in new technologies
that didn't even exist two or three
years ago like 5g and ride-sharing which
were things that we are intimately
involved with in the department of
mobility and infrastructure as of this
month the Pennsylvania Utilities
Commission is embarking on new roles and
responsibilities with the Pittsburgh
Water and Sewer Authority here in the
city yet again serving that key role in
helping to balance the public interest
and the interest of the utilities so
Commissioner places is the vice chairman
of the Commission a beginning from his
appointment in October 1st 2015 was
nominated by Governor wolf he was
elected by his fellow commissioners to
be vice chairman also in 2015
prior to his appointment and the
commission he was the corporate director
for energy and environmental policy here
in Pittsburgh at eqt and previous to
that held a number of roles in the
Pennsylvania Department of Environmental
Protection including deputy secretary
for the office of energy policy energy
technology deployment he's a graduate of
the University of Pittsburgh as well as
a fellow alumnus of the Heinz college
here at Carnegie Mellon University
Commissioner place
[Applause]
thank you very much it's an absolute
pleasure of course to be here for many
reasons one it's great to see ed Rubin
and I teach a class now once a week I
come in on Mondays and it gives me an
excuse of nothing else to come back to
Pittsburgh and come back to Carnegie
Mellon which I have a huge respect for
and I think my son is going to come to
school here next year but that said I
think about I would did want to be
remiss if I didn't note the strength of
this university and the importance of
the graduates and the work that's coming
out of here in so many different
departments and I crossed paths with CMU
alums here there and everywhere locally
regionally nationally and globally and
the heft they bring to the issues that
the technical expertise the and it's
very true of my students I'm not sure
any air in the room at the moment but
the the half the intellectual capability
the dedication the diversity that comes
to through classes here and through the
graduates they run into I couldn't ask
for just a more fascinating place and
that I accidentally by moving to
Pittsburgh 30 years ago I one or another
find my way to see him you and and
remain connected in many different ways
someone once said and I'm sure it's a
proverb that everyone knows it's a
cliche but what said about maybe we live
in interesting times it's unfortunately
and for better worse very true and I
think about the sort of the path I've
taken over the last several weeks or
months and days to get here and I was in
Mexico last week I was in Harrisburg
judicata in cases yesterday I'm here
today I'm in New Jersey on Sunday for
the
Horn ization of PGM States thinking
about demand response and de are and all
the issues floating around at FERC and
PGM then on Tuesday I'm in DC testifying
at FERC on
the Arkana of my back occasionally
aggregate demand response storage
thinking about how all that's coming in
over the next year's and decades those
really challenging issues they're deep
in the weeds they're arcane they're not
getting never going to hit the front
page of anybody's paper but they really
do matter and in the broader context of
grid modernization the technology just
coming in how we're financing it how how
we balance the obligations within the
commission of the utilities ensuring
that they remain viable and making the
investments that will put Pennsylvania
in great stead these this year and the
years going out but also how we balance
that against the challenges of our
residents and ratepayers I wouldn't have
the governor's call to me was of a cold
called if I'd serve on the Commission I
never imagined that I would I was
perfectly content working in the
upstream Oh on a gas base there's still
a lot of work to do thinking about risk
thinking about mitigating risk but I a
friend of mine of Graduate School said
I'm gonna be the smartest guy on the
planet but I'm smart enough to know not
to say no and I thought about
particularly again as I said bring it
back to with that theme I mentioned
about the complexity and the importance
of this time we're in now and
particularly in Pennsylvania and sort of
more regionally to think about the PGM
footprint there is a huge amount of
effort being put into a grid
modernization as I mentioned how do we
finance that how do we ensure that we
are investing in the right places what
does grid modernization mean we're
pulling out pipe or put it we have a
disk accelerated recovery for pulling
out natural gas pipe well needed for
safety reasons we have this aging
infrastructure and it's true across the
Commission we regulate everything from
water to telecommunications wireline
natural gas electricity uber lyft taxis
limousines water dimension water across
all of that space we're dealing with
this many of the same track
and challenging issues that we have this
overlay or underlay of a system that was
built fifty hundred hundred years ago
twenty years ago for many cases of
populations that were larger than they
are today we're dealing with a
relatively static economy and we're
dealing with 1.3 million households I
think in the Commonwealth are living
within 1.5 times at the federal poverty
line so how do we deal with all those
issues that are often in in contrast or
in tension with one another those are
the things that drove me to go to the
Commission again if the Commission is
deep in the weeds it's never gonna
hopefully it doesn't hit the pages of
the paper but what the Commission does
how we regulate this how we do it well
or do it poorly balancing all those
needs does have substantive impact on
across the Commonwealth or economic
competitiveness and the suffering or
lack of suffering of residents the other
thing I was thinking about titling this
chat was about all things FERC all
things PGM in many ways going to the
Commission on that alright I'm I'm
bounded in Pennsylvania this is what I
am this is my mandate this is what I'm
obligated to think about but
increasingly though all the water coming
over the transom all the headwinds and
the issues we're dealing with so many of
them come back to issues that we have a
voice in at fur corn PJM first and
foremost thinking about well I can sort
of work back chronologically but first
energies emergency application to do e
for essentially cost recovery cost basis
rate basing of nuclear and coal
generation I understand where that comes
from
and I understand the challenges they may
face they're facing it from renewables
they're facing it primarily from natural
gas but how do we we've bought into and
we've accepted and I think very
rationally chosen to go down competitive
markets and if we are we essentially we
regulate natural gas or coal and nuclear
about 70% of PJM generation mix that
will undoubtedly creator competitive
markets and you might argue that that we
need to do that we we need to rethink
all this but and I don't want a prejudge
but I will be following comments on this
case on this issue but I'm firm believer
and the benefits of what competitive
markets have brought to us and not
negligent or oblivious to the impacts on
big generators like fresh energy
reregulate encoder natural gas coal
nuclear keeping speaking would be a
substantive challenge I think a very
difficult and Dilla Terrace impact on
the markets based but pulling back a
little bit more to the policy side of
that and I was at FERC this spring
arguing for a price on carbon I
understand the pain of the nuclear side
particularly the nuclear side we have 23
gigawatts of nuclear power in the
Commonwealth that's an important that
it's a fundamentally important zero
carbon resource if we were to if that
was to disappear mass we were even in
part replacing that with renewables as a
multi-decade aleph and a astoundingly
expensive effort so I I understand the
challenges of nuclear I understand what
natural gas is been eating their lunch
but I'm gravely am gravely concerned
about the loss of nuclear power and
particularly the Commonwealth but I am
also interested interested in
increasingly States and if you look to
the north or say to the north whether
it's New York or New England is oh we
have state policies and I think
perfectly valid state policies coming
into our wholesale markets so whether
they're supporting whether it's federal
support or state support for just
regeneration for solar for wind for
storage all of those pieces are coming
in and the states are justifiably saying
we want to have this is our obligation
this is our bailiwick to manage
how we think about our mix and what are
what we should be investing in as a
society as a as a Commonwealth or an
ounce - case but the more you do that
the more you're bringing in subsidized
units into a competitive market and to
date I would argue that it's been small
enough that's been incremental enough
that it hasn't done much substantive
damage people can feel free to disagree
with me and I think that's why we are
discussing this there is an argument
that we are starting to see in
incremental but substantive damage to
wholesale markets by how much of these
resources are coming out of the market
and when you're looking out five years
ten years it's it's a tsunami so as I
said it's sort of trickling down from
the north but we also have an
alternative energy portfolio standard
here in the Commonwealth and
conversations about how that might be
moving forward when it taps out tops out
of 2021 so it's it's fundamentally
important to consider how we distorting
markets energy of capacity markets and
what does that do to some of our
important resources for example one of
the nuclear concerns is that you can
have negative energy prices at night
from wind coming on because they are
making their money off the new federal
tax credits and so they just get paid
they give incentive to to just generate
generate generate and what they're
getting on the wholesale market is
somewhat secondary to Justin to getting
that federal tax credit but then you've
got a nuclear unit that's needed for the
next day it's July 6 it's gonna be
extraordinary hot we're PGM as a summer
peaking resource market so PGM is
calling out we need you on for tomorrow
but these are fairly inflexible units
nuclear and coal so you've got to start
ramping up the day before but you're
dispatching to a market with very low or
negative prices how does that work to me
I get that pain so how we deal with that
and that's a big chunk of the
conversations we're having within PJM is
price Reformation on the one hand if
you're sort of a purist you can argue
that
the pain coming to clear and cold is
from gas and that there's nothing
overtly wrong with using LMP as a market
mechanism it's what's worked well for 20
years it's continuing with some tweaks
to be a pretty good market but there's a
lot of pressure at PJM to rethink that
and think about these questions about
who's setting price and flexible units
are flexible units and how to deal with
some of these market failures of
negative pricing but I would argue that
rather than the tack that like Ohio has
taken or Connecticut and the
conversations around Zacks I think
that's a blunt instrument that it
doesn't drive innovation and very
difficult to get the price right if you
come up with a Zek how you're gonna
price it so what I've been arguing at
FERC and on what I argue within the
Commonwealth here is for a price on
carbon say all right maybe we all don't
want to think about pricing carbon
because it's because we think that
climate change is a fundamentally
important issue but if you are gonna
have a market mechanism that can protect
and remunerated sources like nuclear put
a price on carbon put it in the energy
market that is a pretty nimble
transparent clever way to do it drives
innovation all operators can then say
alright well we've got this price of
carbon how do we innovate our own in our
own space whether it's called for CCS or
driving efficiency more efficiency in
our gas plants then you have a price
signal that is doing what it should do
rather than this
blunt instrument of is that dropping in
just to support a favored you a favor
technology the one other issue come in
you know we've had so he we have all
these different pieces coming in as I
mentioned you know the the do e-2c issue
we're coming out of first energy we have
this question about state policies but
then we
and we had the the FERC do we know poor
out of Scott Perry two or three months
ago there was sort of PG for kicked out
the can down the road saying yeah we're
not going to again rate bass coal but we
want our ISO so think about this
question the Brazilian see that was
raised in that Abidin by secretary Perry
but it's not new to PGM we've long been
in conversations about resiliency and
the value of some of these attributes
that weren't historically valued again
it goes back to the complexity and
modernization of what we're of these
markets they're not so sort of
monolithic one attribute markets and I
used to be just move some electrons and
hey we have a market but there are a lot
of other attributes out there that we
rationally should be pricing but some
are easier than others and some are
quite difficult and resiliency is want
to properly price but I'd argue that we
need to I think we can get there I think
it's complicated and challenging and
capacity constructs are already very
difficult artificial constructs not true
markets and some of this lends more to
that challenge that you already have in
the capacity markets but there is real
rational reason to valued resiliency
it's not 90 days of fuel on site fuel
which is what secretary Perry was
arguing and he argued to backstop that
he looked back to the 2014 pulled of
vortex and said look there was all this
market failure because of lack of
resiliency and he argued that the 90
days of fuel on site fuel would resolve
that resiliency problem but if you look
at the numbers it doesn't it doesn't
solve that problem the polar vortex very
little of it was actually on the on the
generation side and coal actually had
some challenges coming into the market
there was some frozen coal pile issues
but the but additionally if you look at
where the real resiliency challenge is
it's in the the distribution and
transmission of a particular
distribution end and if you want to
tackle resiliency that's where you have
to tap
and more broadly across the whole
panoply not simply by saying the 90 days
if you'll make a difference and we are
I'm running short of time there's a
whole host of other things I wanted to
mention you know evie infrastructure
we're heavily involved with alternative
rate making trying to think about what
the utility the future looks like
decoupling from the throughput of just
more more electrons and more molecules
you move the movie that defends your
revenue base that's not a sustainable
model given especially given the
interest all of us have an energy
efficiency and conservation so giving
more mechanisms for utilities to think
about to restructure what they are what
their business models like that's an
ongoing issue and just a brief one act
40 thinking about solar Pennsylvania
recently passed an in-state solar
requirement and that's in play in the
next two weeks we'll see an
implementation order come out on bat and
that's a challenging space that I may or
may not win on so without and if there's
any questions
to accelerate the adoption of electric
vehicles thanks
yeah the my office a heavy book who's
one of them are you fine yeah real
up-and-coming star a young new member of
my staff
it's cherish the Infrastructure
Committee Committee Subcommittee on the
state's efforts to think about easy
implementation how have we saw the
chicken the egg problem and it's not so
easy and ok we build a bunch of state TV
stations where do we build them how fast
do we build them who owns them and can
you does there's an opportunity for
utilities to own Evi charging stations
or should we just carve it out just for
third parties because we don't want to
rake base something that like an Eevee
charging station philosophically I'm
coming down in the middle and I'm hoping
we can find a way to thread the needle
to say that there are plays there's an
opportunity here for utilities to play
in that space but without closing out
for closing third parties and I think it
can't be done ownership we start to
trickle on and it's another very
prescient issue before us on ownership
regeneration historically again with the
Competition Act we said utilities
throughout the generation business but
when I look at the future look at the
present the future I don't think that
model that black and white hard and fast
silos works very well we've got all this
de arith ever got storage V's all of
that space how do we layer that in and
how do we think about hybrid models that
allow better implementation and better
adoption of many as technologies time
for maybe one more question if we can
make it quick for students at the
University what do you think is the most
important focus for future energy study
yeah it to me and so much that's an easy
answer systems I you know you have to
have all the particular pieces in place
but all of these challenges are just
integrational challenges and I think of
all the pieces none of this is discrete
everything every it's like the
whack-a-mole problem
every time I'm dealing with one issue it
bleeds into all others it's good
monetization it's it's yeah I've talked
about removing pipe and that's also
reducing methane emissions and a
critically important piece but you know
what the business structure looked like
so you need technically technical people
business technically even people you
need the engineering that undergirds
that you need people who can really
think broadly about tough choices and
how we make these how all of this works
and it is it's a mind numbing so the
Gordian knot or pasta plate is pasta
when you try to do it and you really can
as I said deal with one piece discreetly
all of this sort of has to be brought
together and it's the same I will
digress a little bit on the the low
income issues that we can't just deal
with low income issues within the
Commission we got to think of housing
and access and bringing a whole group of
folks together and thinking about that
so we end up being something of a social
service agency so again there's nothing
that I do in my day-to-day work that
doesn't cross across such AB large
spectrum and getting folks that think
about thinking that things ways and are
creatively thinking about how to
integrate all this as absolutely as
fundamental as I can get for me
[Applause]